uh i saw on your instagram you and the
kiddos got a little creative whipped
together some rainbow grilled cheese now
grilled cheese may be the only thing i'm
more passionate about than pro wrestling
okay wwe sports entertainment what is
your secret to the perfect grilled
cheese sandwich
oh well so i just so working with the
kids and trying to make it kid-friendly
it was you know served a couple of
purposes was letting them be we were on
march break letting them feel their you
know some part of the day um but also
like being independent right and like
doing the butter themselves and so doing
the cheese themselves so usually i just
put it on the pan and i cover it the key
to me was covering it while it's on the
pan and that allows the cheese to melt
right just but making sure of course you
can't get that you have to have that
perfect brown it can't be no black you
can't have any black on there has to be
perfectly browned uh but what i
discovered with the kids is like i
couldn't get them into the frying pan
because it's just not good for them and
so we put it in the oven and like a
toaster oven
pretty amazing the well-rounded
gooeyness of it and then the perfect
crisp that you can actually watch to the
perfect brownness good little tip there
norm i like that look at that i'll
exercise it today after work um let's
talk a little bit about the show that's
coming up in kitchener how did you sort
of link up with wwe for this particular
event you know it's been it's been since
2019 since fans have seen you in the
ring and uh what can fans expect from
your involvement as the host of the road
to wrestlemania in kitchener
well i mean wwe we have obviously a
great relationship as one of their hall
of famers and alumni um and i it seems
like a natural fit when the wwe is
coming to toronto or to kitchener or
anywhere in our you know my vicinity
it's you know why not a little
satisfaction to the card right so um
yeah they gave me a call and of course i
said yeah i'd love to host what does
that mean what does a host do
um and so we've been working because at
first it was like you know the whole it
was a holiday show which was gonna be a
traditionalist show of course at that
point but that got delayed yeah you like
that right oh wow
and so we just would like let's work
with the card and see what could be fun
and different you know it's for me it's
an opportunity to come back and work
with some superstars that i've never had
a chance to interact with obviously as
you mentioned i went back in 2019 to
work with charlotte but i did not have a
chance to interact with someone like
becky lynch for example uh bianca
bellaire had not debuted at the time so
you know so there's um yeah like there's
a good chance to like mix it up with
some of the superstars of today and uh
maybe someone that i have or haven't
even interact with before
one person i'm really looking forward to
mix it up with is kevin owens i i called
him canada's favorite superstar some
said maybe i am or i was or whatever it
is but i think the combination of kevin
owens and sure stratus could be a very
stratifying moment yeah i'm looking
forward to that now i'm sure you get
asked this every time it comes up but
considering that this is an opportunity
for you to mix things up do you foresee
a chance to maybe parlay this into
another match down the line
you never know i mean i mean it's crazy
nowadays with social media and here's
the thing wwe really they they go out of
their way to make sure their live events
are
individually
individual and special like every it's
going to feel like a raw experience it's
going to feel like a smackdown
experience it's it's as it's as robust
and you know there's things that you
never know what's gonna happen i mean
like a show
we're in toronto on sunday saturday show
and sunday show are gonna be very
different there's gonna be different
elements they're gonna be different
dynamics um and so i can tell you that
you just never know with social media
now i mean it's amazing what things get
picked up on and it's you know can uh
can manifest and or it cannot manifest
we'll see you know so we'll see what can
happen i but i'm always ready i mean
look did i pack a bag did i put my boots
in them i did i did just in case you
know come on perfect
now someone who may have felt a little
snubs not getting their name mentioned
and i've seen a lot of people online
request this as sasha banks versus trish
stratus is this something that appeals
to you
uh it it wouldn't be not mentioned like
i didn't mention her is that what you're
saying i mean the name just hasn't come
up thus far and i know i know she's
pining for it so yes and i've heard that
i'm running from her which is absolutely
untrue i mean at one point she had done
this promo and said i'm not ready and i
posted a picture of my six-pack and i
said i am ready girl um yeah i listen uh
she's uh and you know it's like it's
like these little moments right so her
and i had like maybe a five-minute
moment in the 2018 like so many years
ago now roy rumble and to this day
people like that's the match we want to
see they just sometimes you just have
this energy that's palpable and you just
have this you know it's like when lead
and i first faced off people oh they
felt that when rock and austin faced off
people felt that so in session i faced
off i mean i felt it too you know it was
a good moment so will we follow up on it
i mean if there's an opportunity perhaps
you know i mean did i wish this was a
smackdown tour yes i did
are there any dream matches in the past
or perhaps in the present that you would
have really liked to come together and
it just never really materialized
um i was i felt very blessed the one
thing i can say like at the end of my
career and why it was one of those like
i felt like i could move on was i had
really
i had worked with everyone that was
available at the time right there was
there was jazz there was molly holly
there was victoria there was mickey
james lita you know we that's there was
a slim pickings at the time as well you
could say right so i really worked with
every single woman at the time that was
available and that's you know when it
was time to move on it's like i mean
what else can i do i've worked with
everyone here and um you know have i
watched people come in and say oh i'd
like to mix up with her yeah like a
sasha banks of course charlotte flair
was someone that i said oh that would be
a interesting match up you know becky
lynch would i like to have exchange
words with her yes and could that happen
in kitchener yes absolutely i love that
who are some of the unsung heroes either
in the ring or behind the scenes during
sort of your formative years in the wwe
that maybe don't get as much of a
mention
well i would certainly say fit finley
was a huge part i mean he does get
mentioned mind you so like that people
know that he's just he was i mean there
would be no true stratus without fits in
there i can tell you that like he really
and and also like you know no um
changing of the guard there was there
wasn't he he was had a vested interest
in the women and helping like for me my
mo at one point had become like and
seeing you know what i knew i could do
but seeing what i was only able to do in
the ring my mo was like i want to change
the perception of what a woman could do
in the ring and in sports entertainment
and so he was on board for that and it
took someone to be on board to be like
yes i see and to see it too i see it too
because like some some of the old school
people didn't see that they didn't see
that the woman could do this other side
of things so him for sure and he's not
unsung he is a some hero but brian
gerwards is someone that he's a writer
wwe and he was a huge you know part of a
lot of my really good juicy work that i
did and working you know with my promos
and we he really um he was really good i
mean obviously he worked at the rock a
lot that was kind of his guy and i got
the chance to work with him he was
really good about tapping into who you
are and then just way over and flying
your personality out there and keeping
it real because i think that's like the
real the authentic superstars are the
ones that people it really resonates
with them because i feel that
and so just you know obviously you take
it you amp it up
you know a few decibels when you're out
there but um yeah he was really fun to
work with and
had a good impact on my career
um shout out to a fine fan over on
reddit who sort of
brought this to my attention but there
is a news post on your website credit to
the layfield report and it says that
along with the wwe wcw and ecw also
offered you contracts in 1999. uh can
you give any insight as to the best of
your knowledge as to what those roles
would have maybe looked like or what was
offered to you at the time
uh i could tell you the money no i'm
just kidding um i'm more interested in
the creative details yeah um you know
they're really it's it's funny because
at the time it wasn't like they were
like okay with the surviving women's
division once you come in you want to
win the woman's title like there was a
point where you know tna had reached out
to me and they wanted you know when it
happened to be around the time when
there was a the new women's championship
was being introduced so it was around
that time and it was a story like pitch
like that because it was like hey women
are a viable part of the show and we
would like you to be a part of it back
then it was kind of like i don't know we
use women on the show would you like to
be a part of it that's what it was right
i knew what i could do i knew uh the
training i'd done and what i could offer
as an athlete to the world of sports
entertainment but i don't know if they
necessarily knew right like and the fact
that you know i didn't not to say i was
seasoned but i had a two-year career
already as a fitness model and i'd
worked internationally i've done
interviews i'd done media so i had that
aspect as well that i could bring in and
that definitely translated when i was
able to get on the mic and uh you know
not only for you know media and
interviews but also just you know to be
a good employee of the company but also
to be a performer as well yeah um when
was the tna offer if i may ask
um well right around the time there was
a new uh women's championship being
introduced
wonderful um
lita did you get a chance to see her
match at the elimination chamber or
parts of it
no does she have a match yeah she
wrestles
so she got one over on you on that she's
my bestie come on no no of course i was
at home cheering her
my son is her she's my my son's
godmother so we were watching her
cheering for her and uh you know it's
great it's it's believe me as like and
i'm sure stone cold steve austin is
going through this right now when you
get back into the ring after being away
from the ring for so long it's uh
nerve-wracking i guess is the first word
that comes to mind but you know you also
know that you've left an impression on
the fans minds of who you are what you
bring to the ring so to be able to live
up to that is it's you know can i and
you don't know honestly you don't know
until you get in the ring for me
personally when i face charlotte i knew
what i could do
practicing i knew but you know the
energy the the do you have the stamina
like do the crowd are they still into
you like will they react am i fast
enough for like you know do i have that
like um you know innate ability to go
the way i did before and you know
thankfully i find that wrestling is like
riding a bike i'm just saying that's
what i discovered after my match of
charlotte but um you know it's um it's
it's exciting to see um someone come
back and just also to like it's a cool
thing to step back into the mix and fans
are still there for you they are
right where they right where you left
off which is really cool
last thing before i'll let you go here
church cause i know we're short on time
um you are one of the judges on the
revival of canada's got talent you're
not the only superstar
pastor president who is sort of mixing
up in the talent space you've got nikki
bella you had cody rhodes why do you
think it is that wwe superstars and pro
wrestlers make such good judges on
talent shows
i mean i would say just even like not
necessarily judges on talent shows but
we like we there's so much we learned as
a wf superstar like the production value
that we bring is is very high uh we
learned you know not to say we're one
take wonder but you got to do stuff live
and you got to do well i just i just
filmed the movie for the last month up
north and it's um you know they were
like like it really i i had all my lines
memorized i didn't bring a script to set
like the entire time which you know i
had a 25 year stress stratford um
actor came to me and said i've never
seen anyone just be on set without your
the script like and i'm like oh i just
what we did in wwe were literally giving
us some bad day hours before we got to
do live and do it well and have it
memorized and that's what we do so
there's it's amazing like what we have
learned and what we can take these
skills that we've learned as a wp
performer and how it translates into
different mediums so um you know we've
got the personality we know how to react
with the crowd we can spot talent
because we've been around it we've
developed it we've developed our own
talent um and so i think it translates
really well i'm going to put you on the
spot i know you studied biology at york
university do you have a fun biology
fact that comes to mind
um
we have 206 bones in our body isn't that
fun beautiful
206 to break inside of a wwe ring right
yeah
trish i'm going to leave you with the
last word whether it's the road to
wrestlemania coming through kitchener
ontario on march 26th stratosphere yoga
whatever it may be anything you've got
left to tell your fans please let them
know well i'm super excited to be
delivering satisfaction to the fans on
the 26th saturday in kitchener um and
also in toronto on the 27th so you know
coming and uh coming back to the fans
i've just shared so much history with
them so like i just feel like this
there's definitely a connection i've
been interacting with them online
everyone's excited um yeah so it's gonna
be a great show and i know we you know
from like as a living in ontario for the
last two years you know we have not had
a chance to get out and have this this
this life so you know it's twofold it's
coming back and
getting some satisfaction but it's also
like getting out again and i think
there's like you know spring just
happened it's like
it's it's a new turning over a new leaf
it's reviving um and we're gonna get out
there and uh have an awesome show
in kitchener and in toronto
you